Florida Governor Ron desantis's not yet
even a real campaign campaign might
already be collapsing and I have to tell
you I have very mixed feelings about it
on the one hand I am enjoying the cringe
and the disasters that are plaguing Ron
DeSantis daily because it's just so
entertaining and it really couldn't
happen to a worse guy on the other hand
I also recognize that Trump's a disaster
and desantis's failings are good for
Trump and it's hard to get behind things
that are good for Trump as well but let
me tell you what's been going on amid
flooding in Florida as well as long gas
lines which are currently happening as a
result of the flooding Ron DeSantis has
been out on a non-campaign campaign book
related events and yesterday he was in
South Carolina at an event with his wife
which went so cringe so quick that it's
actually hard to believe let's look at a
couple of clips of this uh Ron appearing
with Casey DeSantis and they tell a very
coordinated story you know DeSantis is
in this war with Disney and Disney World
down in Florida and they tell the story
about how you know they had a Disney
wedding or something but it was all
before they fell in love at Disney but
it was all before Disney went woke and
it only gets worse from there and the
coordinated and scripted nature of this
it's so cringy and he's pulling his wife
into it and the mega donors that were
thinking about backing DeSantis are
already bailing and I'm going to tell
you about that in a moment I'm getting
ahead of myself let's start with this
event
listen to this heartwarming story of
love from the governor one day she comes
to me and says you know she comes to me
with tears in her eyes and she says sir
talking to my parents and and they were
interested in potentially doing the
wedding at Walt Disney World
oh
I I remember when this broke in the news
everybody thought it was so scandalous
like DeSantis got married at Disney like
yeah it was great back then but he had
one caveat though when I because he was
very gracious Casey DeSantis is even
using Trump's mannerisms interestingly
enough now you go do what you want to do
this is your thing go it's wonderful and
we grew up coming from Ohio going to
Disney we had a lot of fun before they
went woke obviously
um but it was one caveat he said you can
do it however
no Mickey Donald Duck anybody at the
wedding ceremony they actually have a
wedding chat it's really nice and um and
everything worked out it was traditional
in fact you look at our wedding pictures
you wouldn't know that it was anything
you were uh no isn't this just a great
story guys anything out of the ordinary
um but you know we're doing that and
then uh thinking about so this was I
mean this is almost 15 years ago and
then we're no one was thinking like that
somehow this would end up being
something we would be involved with you
know you know going Toe to Toe with them
about about gender ideology and
kindergarten are you kidding me I mean
it's just absurd hindergarten that's
interesting but that's just the way life
works well it's so funny because people
would say oh did you ever see you know
that the governor was going to be the
governor I'm like you know when we when
I first met him he was a cute guy in the
Navy like I I fell for the white uniform
right like it was very handsome he was
like Tom just like hold up does she
actually say Tom Cruise I'm right like
it was very handsome he was like Tom
Cruise it was
I was going to jokingly say just like
Tom Tom Cruise in uh top few Top Gun or
whatever A Few Good Men
um this is this is not helping uh
DeSantis that's the really interesting
thing this obsession with Disney I mean
okay cringe-worthy scripted story fine
this is really not helping DeSantis he's
in South Carolina telling Disney stories
while Florida is in chaos due to
flooding and gas lines and meanwhile
when he is in Florida he's just obsessed
with Disney World to such a degree that
even some Republicans Like Larry Kudlow
are saying this really isn't looking
very good he then did like a more formal
event in South Carolina about the
Florida blueprint I guess trying to
portray the idea that South Carolina and
other red States should copy the
blueprint of Florida which quite frankly
is a very very mediocre State you all
know I love going to Florida I go down
to Miami I go to the you know liberal
areas I'm at hipster cafes and all this
stuff but the truth is that if you zoom
out and look at the state in sum total
it's a very mediocre State not
particularly good or bad when it comes
to infrastructure crime education just
like around 25th out of 50 in most
categories why would you follow that as
a blueprint well here he explains part
of the blueprint is you got to get woke
out and transgender and all this stuff
that's driving donors away the people
also side with us on wanting an economy
where businesses focus on their core
mission of providing whatever service or
whatever they're doing in the economy
and not getting mired into woke
political activism and you see it time
and time again sometimes it's a one-off
like this uh ridiculous thing with with
Bud Light by trying to push the
transgenderism but what they're doing is
do you guys think that anybody has been
pushed into transgenderism by seeing or
hearing that Dylan Mulvaney
drank Bud Light and had some kind of a
spot like the the this the very nature
of you can push people into being trans
is one of the oldest tropes it used to
be about you can push people into being
gay now it's you can push people into
being trans these are corporations
mostly very wealthy powerful
corporations they're trying to leverage
their economic power to change our
country all right they're just doing
what's profitable that's really all
that's going on and DeSantis at this
point seeming desperately uh um obsessed
with Disney and with Bud Light and just
one last clip from this totally deranged
event here is Ron Des Sanctus saying
woke seven times in 20 seconds so
because the woke represents a war on
Truth uh we have no other recourse but
to wage a war on woke we fight the woke
in the schools we fight the woke in the
legislature we fight the woke and the
corporations we will never ever
surrender to the woke mob Florida is
where woke goes to die
yeah there you go so this is not a good
idea
DeSantis donors aren't happy with this
and the polling shows as I told you two
weeks ago most people are on the side of
wokeness but let's now talk about the
trouble that Des Sanctus is creating for
himself with this anti-woke Crusade one
of the difficulties right now of running
against Donald Trump in a Republican
primary
is that if you go completely anti-maga
there may not be enough Republicans in
the party for you to win the primary but
if you go Maga in facing off against
Trump well why would somebody vote for
your Maga when the Maga guy is actually
running and this is the problem that Ron
desantis's donors are now identifying
fascinating article in Business Insider
DeSantis Mega donors Revolt in private
chat saying if they wanted a magic
candidate they would donate to Trump
according to this report really really
interesting stuff a group of wealthy
desanct disowners criticized him in a
private chat Rolling Stone obtained
screenshots of the group chat between
Republican Mega donors earlier this week
a wealthy Florida donor publicly said he
changed his mind about financially
supporting DeSantis this is the latest
indication that the Florida Governor's
wealthy supporters are starting to
revolt with a republican megadona
recently going public about no longer
wanting to support to financially
support DeSantis is yet to be announced
campaign the screenshots reveal these
wealthy Republican donors questioning
the governor's chances of beating former
president Donald Trump in a Republican
primary they're correct to be doing that
the polling is an absolute disaster for
DeSantis lately a series of recent
political missteps including continuing
with his out-of-state publicity tour
while massive flooding took place in
Fort Lauderdale appear to have enraged
these donors Rolling Stone reported
responding to the Fort Lauderdale
incident the media Outlet said one donor
wrote what the f is wrong with Rd
another donor asked who in the group
could reach DeSantis the quickest to
complain about it several other donors
were Furious that the governor referred
to Russia's invasion of Ukraine as a
quote territorial dispute with one
calling on DeSantis to walk back the
comet DeSantis did later go back on the
comet after receiving criticism
um according to a rolling stone source
for familiar with the communication the
donor who called for the walk back wrote
a livid response The Source said quote
my understanding is that the message was
if we wanted an effing Mega candidate we
would donate to Donald Trump other
donors wrote they wanted DeSantis to hit
back harder at Trump with one describing
him as a damn wimp this is this is just
delightful okay so there's a couple
different things going on here yes
DeSantis has Obsessed himself with
expanding the don't say gay bill which
we will talk about on today's bonus show
the Disney stuff The anti-woke Stuff Etc
he also is alienating Florida Mega
donors by leaving Florida and selling
books in South Carolina and Chicago and
wherever else he's been while Florida is
having actual problems now the the issue
there's a couple of different issues
here to talk about
it could be argued and I believe it
could be argued
accurately that if you really want to do
something different in the Republican
party right now it's not DeSantis that
you need to turn to really it's like
Mitt Romney or even further away Liz
Cheney now I'm not saying that the
Republican party right now has enough
people in it who actually want to get
away from Naga and would go for
something like Romney or Liz Cheney I
don't know that that's the case and in
fact it very well may not be the problem
with DeSantis is that the Santos is to
Maga he frames himself as sort of like
the reasonable Maga the effective Maga
the Maga who won't get himself in
trouble because of the lack of decorum
that Trump has or whatever the case may
be but that's a really difficult
situation for Republicans because with
Trump under indictment and yet still in
a commanding lead in the Republican
primary but mostly losing to Biden in
hypothetical general election polls
which may still change
if you're wrong to santis you're in this
situation of well I'm going to be like
Trump but better you can't beat Trump at
Maga you just can't even if it's
accurate that DeSantis would be more
effective at Maga because he wouldn't
get himself into as many self-inflicted
problems As Trump did you can't out Maga
the Maga guy so that's not going to work
if you say I denounce Trump altogether
including trumpism and all of the things
that are wrapped up with Maga right now
at least based on the polling we're
seeing you can't actually beat Trump in
a primary right now so it's really quite
a circumstance between a rock and a hard
place you could say that the Republican
Party finds itself today and this is
what happens when you choose the rage
voters as I explained yesterday they
created anger fear voting
and they blew it up to Historic
proportions recently we didn't just find
ourselves randomly in a situation where
conservative voters are angry and also
misinformed the misinformed anger has
been a strategy for the Republican Party
once they realized they can't win on
policy anymore
and this goes back a long time you could
go back I mean if you read waves of
rancor which is a really good book maybe
out of print now you will learn about
how a lot of this started in the early
AM radio talk radio era so on and so
forth and so desantis's broader problem
is you can't out maga maga but if you
denounce Maga it's not clear you can win
the narrower problem over the last month
or two is he just won't move on he's
sticking with don't say gay he's
sticking with trans he's sticking with
Disney and he's sticking with anti-woke
Trump would have moved on to the next
thing by now and it's not like Trump's
political instincts are necessarily
Perfect by by any means but Trump would
have
either by accident or by advice from
people around him or by Instinct moved
on to something new DeSantis is sticking
with these issues on which he is
actually losing not only many of the
voters but also his donors this is going
to be a fascinating campaign I love the
complete uh Crash and Burn of it and I'm
also aware that there's a strategic
component which is like who would we
rather Biden face
based on the polling we're seeing right
now
we'd rather Biden face Trump if indeed
Biden is going to run for reelection
which he says he is but has not actually
filed for at this point in time let me
know your thoughts make sure you have
subscribed to the YouTube channel at
youtube.com the davidpackman show what a
packed show that I have for you today
one of our sponsors today is Bon charge
I have always enjoyed dry saunas you get
in there your heart rate is up dilates
the blood vessels can soothe achy joints
and muscles it's relaxing it's just a
great way to remove a little stress Bond
charge is the creator of the infrared
sauna blanket which you can enjoy from
home super easy to set up heats up fast
you don't have to have your head inside
like at a traditional sauna at the gym
nice for meditating or reading getting
work done relaxing I have found it to be
a great way to unwind at the end of a
long day easy to clean Sleek lightweight
design easy to store and comes with a
12-month warranty and of course if you
don't love it returns are super easy but
I think you will love it go to
boncharge.com Pacman and use the code
pacman15 for 15 off the link is down
below
remember that you can sign up for
membership with the David packman show
at joinpakman.com all sorts of goodies
and perks available including an extra
show every single day commercial free
audio and video streams of the show The
David packman show soundboard on the
website as well as invites to members
only Town Hall events sign up at
joinpakman.com coupon code 24 starts now
always available to you radical and
repugnant reactionary Republican
congresswoman Marjorie Taylor green
globally debased and humiliated herself
yesterday during a hearing this is a
hearing during which she attacked the
witness
Alejandro mayorkas and also accused
fellow member of the House Eric swalwell
of
um I guess sleeping with a Chinese spy
was the language that she used we're
going to look at that in a moment it
this was so against not only common
sense and decorum but also the rules of
these hearings that Marjorie Taylor
green was banned from speaking for the
rest of the hearing after this
completely unhinged rant here she calls
majorcus a liar
her words are taken down and then it is
noted that she is no longer allowed to
speak no longer allowed to speak
outrage complete outrage we're
in America's children poisoning our
teenagers poisoning our young people how
long are you going to let this go on
congresswoman let me assure you that
we're not
would go on we are fighting the script
no I reclaim my time you're a liar you
are letting this go on in the numbers
well no
actually I want you to take the words
of the speaker down
so in making a ruling on this uh it's
pretty clear that the rules State you
can't impugn someone's character
identifying or calling someone a liar is
unacceptable in this committee and I
make the ruling that we strike those
words
sorry just a point of order legitimate
question you're recognized or thank you
Mr chairman did you move to take the
words down or to strike them Mr Thompson
yeah sorry I just stepped in
to take him down
so that's what we do yeah I mean yeah my
understanding is if words are taken down
that means that the the member can no
longer speak in whatever the proceeding
is
oh boy those words were set
I
that's Congressman Goldman there
personal inquiry point of personal
inquiry that's there's no such thing
that's the best a point of personal
inquiry please that doesn't exist
Marjorie sorry second house when we
strike it does terminate the time of the
individual who is speaking yes so uh the
gentlelady is no longer recognized the
chair now recognizes Mr Ivy I believe uh
can I make a point of inquiry Mr
chairman you can so the the ruling was
that because she used the word liar
um that was taken down which I agree
with yes but but accusing a statement of
fact is very similar to the posters that
uh Mr there's no statement of fact
there's no statement there's no there's
no statement actual basis for the
statement we're not here to debate this
okay and the ruling was made by the
chair that these previous words were not
against the rules of
Clause 1 and Clause 4 of rule 17 but to
tell someone that they are a liar is all
right so Marjorie Taylor green losing
her right to speak these people are
really the worst of the worst of
American politics at this point and I
have to say that
for me one of the it's sad enough
that there are districts in this country
with a majority of those who choose to
vote willing to vote for nonsense like
Marjorie Taylor green that's sad in and
of itself that someone like her can even
become an elected member of the House of
Representatives but the even sadder part
is that there are many people in this
country magatypes who will see this and
they'll say she was right
he is a liar and she is being silenced
because the left perceives her to be
such a strong force again
completely delusional
imaginary made-up scenario bonus clip
she also goes after friend of the show
Congressman Eric swalwell a Democrat on
the committee and it's hard to imagine a
less less classy moment than this
was kept up for months after Kanye West
said that he was going to declare Defcon
3 on the Jews Mr secretary do you
believe that all of us have a
responsibility to elevate our rhetoric
and to denounce anti-Semitism and
anti-police rhetoric in this country so
that Jewish Americans and police
officers can be safer
Congressman I do thank you and I yield
back
the gentleman yields and now I recognize
the gentlelady from Georgia Miss Green
that was quite entertaining from someone
that had a sexual relationship with a
Chinese spy and everyone knows it but
they moved to take our words down
completely inappropriate yeah stand by
just a second while we research the rule
and as we know how that turned out
ultimately she was banned from speaking
truly a disgusting person and it really
shouldn't come as a shock to us that the
same person who was stalking David Hogg
would behave in this way at a hearing
and this gets us to what I really want
to introduce to you today the anatomy of
the right wing propaganda cycle let's
see if we can figure out what mechanism
is at play underlying a lot of these
conspiracy theories we're going to talk
now about the right wing media
propaganda cycle this is not dissimilar
to money laundering in a sense where the
money starts dirty and ends up clean
maybe not a Perfect Analogy but let's
think through the cycle how does the
right Force nonsense and imaginary
issues
into what we might call the mainstream
of the political media discussion the
first step is get some coverage of your
crazy idea or claim somewhere even if it
is not reporting it as if it's true
but reporting that you said it either
way is good and it starts the propaganda
cycle so it might start for example in a
small local news Outlet of some kind
maybe you you'll have a local reporter
tweeting about it and often it will come
from some kind of small time news agency
often understaffed they don't have the
resources to fact check every story
they've got tight deadlines and pressure
from editors so they've got to pump
stuff out so if you can plant a rumor on
one of those platforms you're already
well on your way to starting this cycle
of right-wing propaganda and this could
be you know there are there are cat
litter boxes in the bathrooms at some
schools for the students who identify as
cats that's that's one possibility get
something written about it somewhere get
tweets from reporters even if it's just
it is being claimed that this is going
on
the second step is you take those tweets
or local news articles or whatever the
case may be and you then use social
media to amplify it based on those
initial bits of reporting you use that
to generate more attention about it
because as we know there are so many
people on Twitter that if they see
Marjorie Taylor green or whoever retweet
something that says they've got cat
litter boxes in schools for students who
identify as cats 95 of the people who
see it and retweet it won't check what
is the original Source my I always tell
you
critically analyze primary sources to
try to understand what you're being fed
you can use that initial thing to then
amplify it on social media and then
it'll take on a life of its own social
media becomes a great breeding ground
for amplifying rumor and conspiracy
theory even better if you know how to
use Bots and trolls you can get the
rumors to spread like wildfire and
before you know it they've gone viral on
Twitter on Reddit wherever the case may
be
step three is you want to upgrade the
credibility of the propaganda through an
outlet like maybe an oan or a Newsmax
with the goal of eventually getting it
onto Fox News where the likes of Tucker
Carlson can bring it up not yet
reporting on it but asking questions
right and this is a classic propaganda
technique starts with some local news
story based on conjecture Amplified on
social media by Republicans and then
Tucker says listen
um we need to be allowed to ask
questions about cat cat litter boxes in
school bathrooms the American people
have a right to know about cat litter
boxes in bathrooms and the left doesn't
want to talk about it well maybe the
left doesn't want to talk about it
because there's no evidence that's the
third step in the cycle we need to be
allowed to talk about this and if you
can argue that someone is trying to stop
you from talking about it even better
then you get to the fourth step which is
sort of what we saw yesterday in the
hearing from which we saw Clips earlier
in the show with Marjorie Taylor green
politicians need to start demanding
answers and maybe they'll hold a hearing
and instead of actually asking questions
they just rant and rant and rant and
it's all because the public has a right
to know and this is where these
propaganda stories can really gain
momentum once politicians get involved
in a formal way the rumor is now a story
even if it was always based on nothing
and the media can't ignore it in this
case it's about you know Majorca slide
and all these different things the last
step
is you cement the rumor for an election
cycle by just sort of keeping it going
long enough and that's when it becomes
fact in the minds of many people the
longer you can keep it in the news cycle
the more that a large portion of the
electorate will believe that it is true
it starts to be referred to as truth and
then it can last an entire election
cycle or longer there are so many causes
of this propaganda cycle
but Marjorie Taylor green has added this
new layer which is you just yell the
conspiracy theories at a witness to whom
you're supposed to be asking questions
that is now the epitome of this so what
should we do what can we do the most
important thing is to understand the
cycle and remember if everybody
understood critically analyze primary
sources before you retweet before you
fall for it before you start talking
about it as if it's truth if everybody
understood that if we were Vigilant if
we actually tried to understand where we
are getting these claims from we would
be able to short-circuit these
propaganda Cycles getting going in the
first place of course due to a lack of
media literacy hyper partisanship and
lack of uh of of education and so much
ignorance that we see it's very hard to
short-circuit it but this is the anatomy
of that cycle and Marjorie Taylor green
sort of knows how to take advantage of
it that's for sure we'll have all of the
clips I played today
on our Instagram which you can find at
davidpackman show and of course on our
YouTube channel make sure you are
subscribed to the YouTube channel
youtube.com slash the David Pacman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
I really hate to do this because
um he's a super nice guy who I've
actually had dinner with in a group and
we have a lot of contacts and friends in
common but Robert F Kennedy Jr Bobby
Kennedy Jr has launched a completely off
the rails presidential campaign based on
anti-vax opportunism and pro-putin
talking points and it's really really
sad that this is going on
um as I've mentioned before on the show
uh Bobby Kennedy Jr is sort of like
linked to other folks that are in
Progressive media and uh I once had
dinner with them in Las Vegas and he was
super nice and engaging told interesting
stories extraordinarily polite and just
a you know nice guy to be around and
then the pandemic hit and what has what
was before sort of a more casual
skepticism of vaccines became going
fully anti-vaxx recently pictured with
Michael Flynn just completely embraced
by the most extreme anti-vaccine
elements and earlier this month Bobby
Kennedy filed his candidacy making him
the fourth member of his family to seek
the presidency of the United States he
had an event yesterday in Boston in
which he
um quite frankly ranted for 90 minutes
to the point where even people behind
him were starting to become visibly
uncomfortable here is Bobby Kennedy Jr
praising Donald Trump's instincts not to
close the country down during covet take
a listen
Johnson
on every side and they were all telling
him he had to do that he had the right
instincts he knew that he shouldn't
close down the country
but he did it he got rolled by his
bureaucracy and I'm going to tell you a
quick story
during the Cuban Missile Crisis yeah
there were a lot of those Side Stories
which is why this thing ended up lasting
an hour and a half it is important to
mention that uh there is wide reporting
that many members of the Kennedy family
are supporting Joe Biden over Bobby
Kennedy Jr in the primary and I guess I
should mention Bobby Kennedy Jr running
as a Democrat although I don't really
know at this point sort of like what
policies line them up with the
Democratic party uh here is a clip sort
of in the middle of this extremely long
90-minute rant and as you can see uh the
folks in the background their
expressions have changed pretty
dramatically and it was it was quite
painful I will say I'm in a lawsuit
involving Amazon for censoring one of my
books so they were censoring people who
criticized the lockdowns while they were
raking in the money from them and I it's
hard not to laugh because the the crowd
he lost the crowd the way Trump loses a
crowd just going on and on and yes he
talks about he's being censored and uh
now he's he's gonna fight back what
censoring what on Earth is going on here
this is what this is what happens when
you censor somebody for 18 years
I got a lot to talk about
they shouldn't have shut me up that long
because now I'm gonna really let loose
on them for the next 18 months they're
gonna hear a lot from them
so listen I support anybody who wants to
challenge Joe Biden for the Democratic
nomination absolutely do it here's just
a guy who I I can't say is a better
alternative to me in absolutely any way
he of course got the hero's welcome on
Tucker Carlson's program last night
after this very brave launching of an
anti-vaxx campaign for president and
what he did was he showed up on Tucker
Carlson's show and he repeated pro-putin
propaganda about death rates in the uh
invasion of Ukraine by Russia
nobody talks about this there's 14 000
Ukrainian civilians who have died by 300
000 troops the Russians are killing
ukrainians and a seven to one to eight
to one ratio they cannot sustain this
well we're being told about this war is
just not true
no it's not true there you go so finding
common ground with the pro-putin people
and with Tucker Carlson this is a claim
based on a fake doctored report of
Russian propaganda
put out that has been conclusively uh
debunked and it is still being repeated
by Bobby Kennedy Jr to Tucker Carlson so
essentially an anti-vaxx pro-putin
campaign I guess it is truly sad to see
this Bobby Kennedy Jr not only a really
nice guy but a long history of powerful
work defending the environment
protecting the planet dealing with
climate change River Keeper Alliance uh
attorney working on these issues it's
genuinely depressing to see what has
happened with Bobby Kennedy Jr and also
I guess now at his rally his wife the
actress from Curb Your Enthusiasm and
other shows Cheryl Hines was there and
and introduced him and seemed to be
behind the whole thing there was quite a
bit of drama involving her during the
um the heart of the pandemic wherein
while Bobby Kennedy Jr was out rallying
railing against vaccines uh Cheryl
required everyone who went to their
holiday party to be vaccinated and sort
of it seemed as though maybe she wasn't
on board with the entire thing but
apparently now she is so this is not a
candidate I will be supporting I don't
yet know who I will be supporting in the
Democratic primary because I don't yet
know who all the candidates are going to
be uh Joe Biden has not even announced
that he is running for reelection so
when I know who I will be supporting I
will let you know the first step would
be let's figure out if Joe Biden is
actually running for reelection Donald
Trump is now visibly panicking about not
only the existing arrest that already
took place but about possible
forthcoming arrests and he has declared
that Joe Biden is guilty in another one
of these sick orange swollen videos with
the bizarre Lighting in this clip Donald
Trump attacks the special prosecutor
Jack Smith as a lunatic and says that
Biden is guilty not exactly Law and
Order is it to say someone who hasn't
even been uh in charged or there's no
evidence that Biden's guilty of anything
he said no he he's guilty Trump hating
prosecutor Jack Smith a lunatic
should go get Biden for what he did he's
very guilty very
Biden is not just guilty he's very very
guilty and this is of course another
example of what I spoke to you about on
geez was it Tuesday or Wednesday the
abandonment of their own stated
principles by Republicans were about Law
and Order and due process
are you though because you want the
January 6 rioters to get special
treatment you want Hillary and you want
Biden and you want Obama
locked up even though they haven't even
been charged with any crimes and you're
now declaring people guilty of course
without ever explaining what crimes you
even think they committed when people
ask Trump what what is Obama gate anyway
he says you know what it is it's the
biggest political crime of the century
oh yeah but like what laws were violated
no that's that's fake news that question
is fake news this entire thing
continuing
with Donald Trump going through his
typical grievances including that every
investigation of him is a scam eighty
percent of the public think that
your former president Donald J Trump me
is being treated very unfairly for
political reasons and due to the fact
that he is leading in all of the polls I
love this third person stuff
key Trump is leading
eighty percent of the people agree with
that I say these prosecutorial scams
that hoaxes are all about election
interference and Republican leadership
must get tough and must be smart but
we're not going to have a country left
yep there will be no country left if
Trump is held accountable for the things
he allegedly did Trump then uh Trump
Furious I guess now with Republicans who
don't like him continuing to be furious
he actually tells people if you turn on
the TV even if you're watching Fox News
if you see Karl Rove there or Bill Barr
or Paul Ryan you got to turn that TV off
you see rhinos Karl Rove Bill Barr or
Paul Ryan on your television screen just
turn to a different station or turn it
off turn off that set as fast as you can
you're frankly better off watching
Democrats they are the worst yep so this
is basically I don't want you to hear
any of the things that some Republicans
are saying about me because not every
Republican like me so just turn the TV
off kind of treating his followers like
little children just don't even let them
watch it don't let them think for
themselves Trump then going back to his
obsession about Chinese restaurants and
Chinatown when it comes to documents
when will they be looking at the Biden
documents many of which were brought in
from Chinatown
and then sent to Boston
is this why China paid him and Hunter
millions and millions of dollars now
many of you are wondering what the hell
is Trump talking about Chinatown
Trump seized on some story whose details
I previously researched and sort of
escaped me now where there was a period
during which the during which Nara the
National Archives
was temporarily storing some documents I
believe for a Presidential Library
in a building that previously housed a
laundry and also a Chinese restaurant if
I recall correctly and now it's about
China Town and it's it's it's just
Insanity that this is still something
Trump is focusing on and then of course
lastly this is a common way that Trump
wraps speeches declaring himself the
most honest person ever anywhere not
just among American Presidents but just
anywhere after eight years of various
politically motivated investigations
hoaxes scams and witch hunts this must
make me the most honest and honorable
man anywhere in the world must nobody in
history has ever been through the
scrutiny that I have
we're going to make America great again
we are going to get rid of these
lunatics there you go well we I am all
for getting rid of lunatics that is
absolutely the case so what is causing
Trump to be triggered in this way it's
actually not completely clear so let's
go through it if you look at polling the
polling is like not great for Trump in
the general but it's very good in the
primary we look at recent general
election polls we've got a yougov
economist poll a b-plus rated poll which
was released two days ago Biden versus
Trump this one has Trump up one among
registered voters and it has uh Trump up
for among uh what is the and I actually
don't remember what the a stands for is
this all voters will registered I'm not
sure what that is a okay uh there is an
earlier yougov poll sponsored by Yahoo
news which has Trump up to over Joe
Biden but with only something like uh 70
of respondents choosing one or the other
um Biden versus Trump in a morning
consult poll it's Biden plus three okay
so like it's roughly even with Biden you
could say if you then look at Republican
primary polls Trump is just crushing I
mean again as I said before unless
something really changes unless DeSantis
enters this race
with some kind of Blockbuster and
something terrible happens to Donald
Trump I don't see how DeSantis is going
to be the guy to beat him in a new
yougov poll Trump is ahead of DeSantis
by 22.
um in a Yahoo news you gov poll Trump is
ahead of DeSantis by 24. University of
New Hampshire Poll for the New Hampshire
primary Trump leads by 20.
um it it's really very strong for Donald
Trump so is the polling the reason that
Trump is flipping out
doesn't seem to be is it that Donald
Trump is catching wind that actually
being under indictment in New York
already and potentially more forthcoming
indictments are really going to get in
the way of him being able to run the
campaign he wants to run it when he
wants to do more rallies in the entire
thing that could be and in fact there
have been rumors that by the end of this
month April although at this point it
doesn't it's not clear it's going to
happen there were rumors that Trump's
second arrest was going to take place uh
in the last week of April maybe Trump
has caught wind of that it's not really
clear and then thirdly is there
something going on in terms of
fundraising and big donors where Trump
is quietly hearing that there are big
donors he would like to have in his
Corner who are going to either wait or
go to SanDisk or someone else it's a
total hypothetical and again we are not
seeing evidence of that in fact at the
top of the show today I told you about
the reality that many DeSantis would be
Mega donors are furious with them
and saying what the hell is he doing
leaving Florida when there's flooding in
gas lines uh I'm not going to donate to
DeSantis so that also doesn't seem to be
the reason that Trump would be so
triggered we don't actually know the
answer and I think one of the things we
have to come to terms with is that with
Donald Trump there is often no obvious
explanation for his erratic Behavior
after the break I am briefly going to
talk to you about a more specific sort
of kerfuffle that came out of this uh
video which is Trump's much more direct
focus on Ron DeSantis which has a lot of
interesting things underlying it we'll
get to that after the break
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show all right
I uh deliberately separated out this
particular portion of Donald Trump's
latest unhinged speech that he gave uh
or statement to the camera not really a
speech kind of more just a video I don't
even know what to call it at this point
it's how he's communicating with his
so-called followers I wanted to separate
it out because there's a much bigger
story behind it that's building uh among
the Republican party at the top of the
show I told you that there are many
DeSantis potential Mega donors who are
furious with the santis and getting away
from him but there's an another movement
that's going on there's a movement
that's going on from within the Trump
Camp to pound and Crush DeSantis so
badly now before he even announces with
the goal of getting DeSantis to not even
try wait till 2028 or forget about it
all together is sort of the idea the
right wing Washington Times reports
DeSantis has Trump campaign's foot on
his throat
seen as true threat to ex-presidents
2024 hopes and the idea of what's going
on here is that Trump on some level does
worry that if DeSantis did get into the
race
doesn't mean to sand his would win but
it would be a fight that maybe Donald
Trump doesn't want to have and so the
idea is maybe Trump can get DeSantis to
not even get involved in this race
altogether
and this brings us to this particular
moment from the speech from the video I
don't know why I keep calling it a
speech from the video that Donald Trump
published yesterday
where he just ranted and raved about the
santis's poll numbers and this is
considered part of the effort to prevent
the contested primary Trump's still
winning by 20 in most polls but what
would be a contested primary and instead
open the door for Trump to face off
against twos threes and fours as we call
them people polling two three and four
percent and have a much easier path to
the Republican nomination take a listen
to this getting lots of job requests
from people currently working for the
Social Security Medicare cutting
the sanctimonious campaign
Ron's poll numbers are dropping so fast
and furious that many people are
speculating he's not going to run
he just hired Kiss of Death Jethro he's
a kiss of death I can tell you a lot of
the people that we defeated who were
represented by jeffrow Kiss of Death
who dropped young Kim you know who young
Kim is
to see if he can help
and he's going to help Ron but I don't
think he's going to help him much
because I'm leading in Texas by 42
points Iowa and New Hampshire by a lot
overall by close to 40 and by 10 against
the scammer Joe Biden okay so Trump is
not wrong Trump is genuinely polling
really really well uh in the Republican
primary and if you look at just the
trends this is real clear politics is a
chart of the trends I'll describe to you
what's going on you see a purple line
which is Trump and you see a green line
which is DeSantis and you do indeed see
that starting around March 11th and
accelerating dramatically around March
27th Donald Trump has gained
significantly in the Republican primary
polls and Ron DeSantis has started to
decline significantly and the decline
doesn't seem to be stopping right now I
already spoke with you earlier in the
show show there's a number of different
reasons that this is going on there's a
Washington Post article after
high-flying start DeSantis hits
stumbling blocks on the road to 2024
this article does mention the Republican
Mega donors that are moving away from
Ron DeSantis this mentions that many
Republicans aren't thrilled with the
six-week abortion ban again it's
potential Mega donors maybe not because
they personally are pro-choice but they
recognize the direction that the country
is and continues to has been moving and
continues to move on that issue they uh
believed that DeSantis is making
unforced errors which include not only
signing that abortion ban but having to
clarify the comments on Ukraine being a
territorial dispute as I mentioned he's
striking Republicans as distant in
personal interactions and on and on and
on but he's still in second place so
there is now sort of this overt it's no
longer it's no longer a secret I don't
know that it ever was but it's no longer
a secret that Trump would like to knock
out DeSantis and get him not to even run
is that likely to happen
there's two different perspectives on
this perspective number one
is even if you're only polling 30 or
what was it exactly in that real clear
politics uh DeSantis is polling on
average 24 right now even if you're only
polling 24 percent
it's difficult to get away from running
when it will put you on the national
stage up against Trump which is a great
opportunity to get attention which can
backfire if Trump makes fun of you in a
way that's effective but gives you a ton
of national attention and you probably
to some degree think to yourself I mean
listen Nikki Haley announced then she's
polling what is she polling she's
polling three percent and uh you know
ramaswamy announced then he's polling
one percent I haven't announced anything
yet and I'm polling 24
I'm sure I can build that number if I
actually announce and run so on the one
hand that would be the argument that
makes it very difficult for you to say
I'm not going to run on the other hand
if you're patient it does seem logical
to me to think you know I'm pulling 24
but what's my ceiling is is most of the
you know Haley Pompeo Cheney is is all
of that just going to go to Trump who's
already over 50 percent
do I really have a shot here or do I
have a better shot at waiting until 2028
what might interfere with that
is that there is uncertainty you don't
know what will happen to your political
career between now and 2028 and so so
maybe it is difficult for DeSantis to
get away with from it I don't think that
it is a hundred percent that DeSantis
runs but I think it is the most likely
outcome at this time and from the people
I've spoken to in Florida who are sort
of like tangentially surrounding the
DeSantis Camp uh there is a lot of
confidence that the decision has already
been made by DeSantis that he's not
going back and that no polling collapse
sort of going to zero is going to
dissuade him from running we'll watch it
and we'll follow it very closely all
right I don't know why I find this next
clip so damn funny but I was laughing
hysterically this morning watching this
there's this kooky Republican
Congressman James Comer James Comer is
obsessed with talking about how they're
going to go after Joe Biden they're
going to investigate this they're going
to get them they're going to get Biden's
family now you all know that that's
ridiculous but James Comer appeared last
night on the Hannity Fox news program I
guess the Hannity Fox news program now
is shot with a live audience and despite
there being no evidence of crimes
committed by the Biden family Comer is
claiming to be super confident that they
are closing in the walls are closing in
on the Biden family so this is this is a
silly nonsensical thing but Hannity's
crowd starts cheering when he says it
they just cheer
do they not realize that the walls
aren't closing in on the Biden family I
don't know but there's a little detail
that I don't know why this is so funny
when the crowd starts cheering and this
is very visual so I'll describe it to
people who are listening when Comer says
this the crowd starts cheering the
camera pans to the live audience for
Hannity's show and you see two people I
don't know if they're a couple or if
they just happen to be sitting next to
each other
and they are clapping and chewing gum so
aggressively why are you chewing gum at
a live taping of a TV show like I don't
know why I find it so weird but I could
not stop laughing when I saw this this
morning check this out it's all
ridiculous the the walls are closing in
no they're not the crowd cheering what
you guys do you guys believe this but
the gum chewing is just too much for me
it all points back to Joe Biden and
we're going to continue in you until we
get the truth to the American people but
I can say this shot the walls are
closing in on the Biden family
we appreciate you being with us thank
you
[Applause]
evil chewing gum they look like
ruminants chewing their cud what the guy
on the screen left the gum is sticking
out of his mouth why why is there so
much gum chewing happening during this
show and of course the truth is the
walls are not closing in on Joe Biden's
family if they're closing in they're
closing in at what we might call a
glacial Pace well we might have the neck
we might have the next ice age or
Trump's health care plan before the
bidens actually end up indicted so
people very excited on the Hannity
program for something they're being told
is happening which simply is not
happening I'm not a betting man but
that's something I'm willing to bet on
now of course remember I'm for Law and
Order so I say
if there is evidence of criminality
against anyone whether it's a Democratic
president a Republican president a
speaker of the house a vice president if
there's evidence that someone committed
a crime
investigate it if you find that indeed
it looks like they did commit a crime
charge them
try them do I'm not saying don't do it
I'm just saying I don't believe that
there is going to be any evidence that
the Biden family committed any crimes
all right let's move on we have a
voicemail number
that number is 2192 David P you know
I've said it many times before
criticize me for things I said if you
don't like them if I got it wrong
but don't criticize me for things I
haven't talked about here is a caller
who is furious with what I said about
manosphere Darling Andrew Tate
except I don't know what this guy's
talking about I didn't ever say any of
this stuff listen to this
Milo Kuklinski what does that even mean
no
it's not as funny that you guys have
never talked about everything one thing
pretty much at all and then all of a
sudden when he gets arrested you guys
you guys make videos about him what
what I'm getting arrested one of the
videos coming out talking about how uh
he was released and uh and why don't you
guys apologizing apologize for what what
you said you guys were all convinced
that he was pretty much Guilty by all
the talents of he was your sex
trafficking and whatnot and now he's
been let go after four months
it's crazy to think I I once upon a time
the Liberals were born were against the
government and all of those Shenanigans
and now it's the Trump supporters and
now you guys are for government
everything you guys are not questioning
questioning anything government related
dude I don't know what the hell you're
talking about so I Milo kuklinsky I
don't know what that's about
as far as I'm concerned uh there are two
claims made about me one that when
Andrew Tate was arrested I said he's
pretty much guilty and two that I had
never spoken about Andrew Tate prior to
that both statements are false first and
foremost I've spoken about Andrew Tate
in a segment about the manosphere in
which I talked also about uh liver King
and Jordan Peterson so I have spoken
about Andrew Tate once before
secondly I haven't weighed in at all
about the Andrew Tate arrest and in fact
during a live stream someone said David
what do you think about Andrew taint
being arrested and I said I don't think
anything I don't have anything to say
it's just it's not really a topic on
this show I don't know he's accused of
crimes I don't know I just I just have
no idea so listen I'm glad to defend the
things I've said on this show
and I'm glad to correct things I've said
on this show if they are wrong
but don't call me about things I haven't
said call someone who's actually said it
but you're wasting everybody's time we
have a fantastic bonus show for you
today
Florida has expanded its don't say gay
rules to include up to and including
12th grade
and this is part of why Republican Mega
donors are not happy with Rhonda Sanctus
we'll talk about it on the bonus show
secondly there are more calls for
schools to drop Native American mascots
and some schools could end up losing
State money over this very interesting
what's going on and lastly we now have
two shootings that have taken place
stemming from a mistaken address and
this is putting the spotlight back on
stand your ground laws the way we really
haven't seen since stand your ground
laws were at the heart of the George
Zimmerman Trayvon Martin killing years
and years ago so we're going to talk
about stand your ground when producer
Pat joins me on the bonus show oh the
bonus show where you want to make make
money sir everybody else that makes
money to find themselves as bad that's
exactly right we're going to be making
some money on the bonus show you can
sign up at joinpakman.com you can get
instant access to the bonus show the
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show the members only soundboard
Obama as well as getting invited to the
member-only town halls the next of which
will be announced very soon sign up at
joinpakman.com use the coupon code
indicted or indicated both work both get
you a discount I'll see you then